when I first met Kennedy back in the
late nineteen forties she was actually a
Republican that's true is it yeah and
had a little pink elephant tattooed an
accessible spot still got it how did you
come out of the darkness it's the bright
light of libertarianism um by your
graceful hand because you gave me Iran's
Objectivist epistemology over dinner and
you're like you have to read this and I
didn't understand this libertarianism
that you spoke of because you were so
smart and you would bash all these
liberals and I would I would not and
acquiesce and say yes yes that's it I
agree but then you would also badmouth
Republicans for being social hypocrites
and you would sort of mutter under your
breath you're not a Republican you're a
libertarian what does that even mean I
didn't understand and luckily under your
mentorship I came to see the light and
it took some years well I'm glad you
arrived I've move on from Iran by the
way just so you know I'm very sad to
hear that but Iran didn't like
libertarians now she hated libertarians
the you amazed how you remembered all
this stuff I can't remember last week
but you're remembering back 20 years did
you have to really canvass people and
extract their memories I did and it was
a it was really amusing because as I
started going through the stories and I
would call people for stories about the
beach house and the Video Music Awards
and almost getting fired you know people
would say the same thing like oh I've
forgotten that and then they would
remember details that I either didn't
know about or had long forgotten and
mouse that was true with you you read
the book and you realize there's a story
in there it's patently false that's true
let's not say what these things say it's
actually a good story so who cares that
sleeping dogs lie
trying to be professional so I have a
tattered list without well done the you
actually got to make friends with pop
stars I never did that but you guys you
were a hardcore journalist I was a VJ I
was wearing pajamas and the but unique
Rani friends with these people and I
think we have the same estimation of
Courtney Love it was like a nightmare
right oh god is that putting it too
softly it really is and and I wrote some
harsh things about Courtney in my book
because I had
to be honest um and you know I have the
chance to take him out through the
editing process and I didn't kiss she's
nuts
that's true she's jealous is Dan in one
of the most memorable scenes that I
constantly relive in my mind is when you
were interviewing Madonna on a platform
at the Video Music Awards live and
Courtney Love started emptying her
makeup bag and throwing it at your head
it's also hi Courtney that's true that's
true you know that you know that she and
Russell Crowe actually used to write
poetry together embalming I asked him
about that one did you really do this
yeah as if what would be wrong with it
so she must perhaps she has reserves
that we're not seeing
she always needed a male collaborator
though I found that very interesting I
thought that that was kind of a weakness
because she told me that she wasn't
interested in competing with the other
women um the day whether it's Liz Phair
or Kim Gordon that she wanted to compete
with the boys maining Trent Reznor and
Billy Corgan or do something with them
yeah I compete I mean but there you also
you're also friends with Billy Corgan
isn't he an Alex Jones prison planet guy
that were you
you know Billy is one of those people
and libertarian means many things to
many people doesn't mean that though
away from when he said he considers
himself to be a libertarian but he
believes a lot of these conspiracy
theories that are not grounded in
reality or logic Billy are you here what
a wonderful surprise
you're also pals with Dave Navarro a man
who I also have to take the test cuz he
collects John Wayne Gacy clown paintings
John Wayne Gacy being the famous
torturer and murderer of children I
don't find that to be ironic
no he's and I didn't marry him he was
not the date I challenge people you have
to drop them all Kurt whatever you tell
me I'll do you I seriously am your
zombie [ __ ] robot and
if there's no David abroad will make
itself do I need to fiddle with his
brakes no but he he did and that was one
of the reasons I was attracted to him
because he had a dark sense of humor so
when you walked into his kitchen he had
one of those doctors office urine
collectors with dark yellow substance
and the label said gene Hackman I was
hooked
well okay that's funny it's funny I go
but I I agree if it had been Bob Ross it
would have been worn out did you sort of
left there was a little tension when you
left MTV did you did you mend fences
before you left or did you just with who
with MTV in general I'll explain this in
the book but yeah it wasn't tension so
much as my own personal anxiety because
I knew I was going to leave I knew that
my contract was up in December of 1997
and I had been dating my boyfriend for
two years and I really wanted to be with
him he was never going to move to New
York and I knew that I would if I was
really in love and wanted to pursue an
adult life I would have to be with him
and I'd already been on MTV for five
years and it's one of those things like
how long can you be a VJ before you
overstay your welcome at the party and I
wasn't really interested in finding that
out but it was a great source of anxiety
and I remember one story in particular
that I get into in the book is we were
flown to Texas and Tony de santé might
remember if you're here Tony and if you
could fill in the details of us were
flown to Texas to interview Evander
Holyfield at his gym and we would held
hostage in our hotel rooms for three
days because at any moment that champ
was gonna call and we're gonna take the
entire crew the entire production over
to his gym and interview him probably
for 20 minutes and and he prayed on it
and he decided at the last minute that
it was revealed to him that MTV was
immoral and horrible and polluted young
minds so after he was like three days of
sitting in a hot hotel room in Houston
Texas he decided that he wasn't going to
do the interview and that's when I
wanted to take a handful of pills yeah
and it was then that I was going to
write Andy a letter and be like dude I'm
so burned out Andy Sean was my boss at
the time
and then my boyfriend Dave was in a
motorcycle accident he broke his back in
August of 97 and he had surgery and he
looked at me from his hospital bed and
he was very vulnerable and I was very
sad and I realized I knew I loved him
but I didn't realize how deeply I loved
him and he said I don't want you to be
my girlfriend anymore I want to marry
you and I was like oh baby I was the
sweetest man look it's okay I'm sorry
but no he really is like he's he's so
awesome I wish he was here tonight but
Kennedy's a great one of your Gradius
appearances I think was the thing with
Rudy Guiliani some address too many New
Yorkers on a stage and she's standing
behind Rudy who's rabbiting on about
something and fellating a microphone on
camera just brilliant just the greatest
thing it said you are one of the few
people who thought so
un Sumner Redstone did not share the
same opinion that night uh summer hmm oh
it was a lovely man I'm sure but for the
first time and this was a big night this
was 1994 the Video Music Awards and Kurt
and Tabitha and and the entire MTV News
organization were always the broadcast
before the Video Music Awards before and
after and MTV News was an important part
of all of these big events the VJs not
so much like we were lucky to get a
ticket to the Video Music Awards no
plus-one
but this year in 94 they asked a Bill
Bellamy and me to present the viewers
Choice Award which was a huge honor and
it was also my 22nd birthday and this
was an enormous night and I was so
excited and I had this great blue
tie-dyed crushed velvet Todd Oldham suit
and you know purple mac lipstick and and
I was feeling it my brother had flown in
and Roseanne was the host that year and
she took the stage and insinuated that I
had given Rush Limbaugh a [ __ ]
backstage Rush Limbaugh wasn't even
there
so when it came time to solicit votes
for the for the viewers Choice Award it
was it was Bill Bellamy who is smiling
and handsome and Rudy Giuliani who was
completely clueless and had lobbied MTV
so hard to come back to New York City
for the VMAs and me standing next to the
mayor and our faces go up on the big
screen at Radio City Music Hall and
everyone starts booing and I don't know
why they're billing I just assumed
because I've been there for two years
and I had run into a lot of hatred and
polarization I assumed they were booing
me and so what do you do you got to take
the moment back from them and the only
thing that occurred to my young still
virginal mind was I bet I could give
this microphone a blow job get a few
laughs and and that's what I started
doing and I watched the tape one time it
was Doug Herzog's going-away video which
is now miraculously disappeared when
Rudy Giuliani ran for president no one
can find this day and I got this wild
look in my eye and Ike it looks like
possession like all of us that I'm
standing there kind of oblivious and
then I look a little worried and then it
clicks and I I do this kind of like
nutty Courtney Love look at the
microphone was delighted the mayor had
no idea and Sumner Redstone was furious
to that point he had no idea who I was
all he knew is he wanted me gone from
the earth and he probably knew you
survived and that was because of Andy
shown and and actually Lauren Levine
who's here tonight I went up to Tom
Freston at an after-party and made some
joke about how funny that wasn't Tom
just met her with like icy silence and
and I will fire you the second stare and
she's like okay I'm gonna go get
cocktail I'm good to see you guys and
somehow I kept my job I had suppose five
is there's a great rain that you had how
many years were you on MTV not as many
as you are you were there for one like
nobody's been on his life as long as I
know and people ask me all the time like
it's Kurt still at MTV and I say yes he
is why not no one I know watches anymore
so
you always get that question too I mean
there there are people always come up to
you and say why can't MCD be like it was
back in the 90s and I always say you
know nothing is like it was back in the
90s if you want to watch videos now you
just go on YouTube yeah but people seem
to want to go back or something to hear
that a lot from people I hear that more
than anything when I talk about my book
people whisper Lee do the thousand-yard
stare knife ah
remember when MTV played videos and I do
and it was great and it was fun it was
gainful employment but music is so
different now media is so different now
and you know they really cocaine is
cheaper so thank God for Columbia Kurt
yeah because that in Starbucks that is
in East Village freebase right there but
you know my old boss Andy shone is
starting a music channel so we'll see
he's starting a channel with Diddy
because there are enough people in their
estimation who want music on TV again
what could go wrong with that I'll be
great hardly anything hmm okay well uh
do you have any questions for Kennedy I
think you do or her like you know it's
not about you it's about you I know but
I I used to love walking past her office
because it was the 90s and you know we
were just newly leaving sexual
harassment because we all had to take
like to get into this well you have to
ask but we all have to take these anti
sexual harassment seminars after Anita
Hill so we would stop talking about
pubic hairs on her coke cans and and I
would walk past guards office and it was
like last bastion of political
correctness because her it would be
smoking he would have a snifter of
something probably apple juice and and
he'd be smoking in his office and
there'd be people wheezing walking by
dramatically increase x-man
or you would always answer my questions
I think the only thing that you showed
any annoyance about at least with me was
when we would be in the makeup room
together and you would be in the chair
getting your makeup done which was there
it was hard to get you to sit still for
five minutes to put makeup on you but
you would eventually do it and and I
would be spraying my hair with
conditioning spray trying to do Harry
figures it was so big I would spray you
in the face a night remember perk or an
Audrey are makeup artists going girl can
you please wait till Kurt leaves my
chair it's hard enough to get him in
here in the first place I remember we're
going to one of those meetings it was
the Golden Age of Peters even it wasn't
more species than today but there was a
meeting where they take everybody bust
them three hours away to have a meeting
about feeling feel good
so I remember Everett we were in a
meeting where there was a facilitator
telling about a hundred people to
imagine being a tree and your supposed I
was just unbelievable so there was that
did you imagine your back Oh tree yeah
it was it was a strange there's a
strange collaboration of things I was
never allowed on the on the group
excursions Oh
after the rob-stuart incident what was
that anyways that he was backstage at
the Jon Stewart Show he's going to be a
guest when Jon Stewart had a show on MTV
and Lorne the mean purpose you poor
thing I'm so sorry Lauren is my dear
friend she was my boss for a long time
and so many times she had to call and
reprimand me for something and she would
say I have to tell myself you're 20 I
always forget in dog years but
emotionally I'm like four um but Robster
was backstage and I was feeling very
impulsive and had a belly full of
brownies oh and and I was PMSing into
Rod Stewart was just ripe for the
plucking and I went into my guy rod um
did they really pump a quarter semen
from your stomach
and then I thought for a minute about
what that would actually entail Mike how
like who had the Pyrex quart sized
pitcher and you know it's like did they
refrigerate it and wait like how many
people would it take to make a quart
like that's a lot more than you think I
mean that's an entire aircraft carrier
full of several bands seamen yeah uh and
and he said I'm so sorry Julian I know
it's the Museum of sex and really should
keep it clean you're absolutely right
and he said he laughed it off he said oh
that old thing old road he made that up
blah blah you know the guy that's a fun
rumor isn't it and then I was like yeah
that's fun Thanks and I left and they
the other half of the brownie tray and
then Rachel Hunter to whom he was
married at the leg a supermodel Rachel's
mom or whatever that stupid song is um
he was married to her and as they were
walking out you know he seemed fine but
she was like don't you believe the
rumors you him yeah and then the next
day I was called into Lauren's boss's
office and I was certain he was about to
have an aneurysm because he was yelling
at me with such intensity the veins were
actually it's sternal to his neck he was
so angry and there had been you know a
number of things that I had done prior
to that and they were all in the name of
fun and love but some people just didn't
understand you always did Kurt and I
want to thank you for that you never
judged me I do thank you
does anyone have a question for Kennedy
raise your hand real high yes
libertarian hi Jim hi how are you candy
I used to read a recent magazine while
watching you on MTV so hey that's a
chocolate peanut butter you do is so
delicious it's not a sexual thing is it
well okay my question is is now thanks
for that
libertarians are off in their own worst
enemies when trying to communicate their
philosophy and positions to non
libertarians so what advice or
suggestions do you have on how we could
do that better
um beyond fill a microphones some a
gentler perhaps to the opposite of what
Nicholas bee does
I'm telling getting absent Nick
Gillespie no actually I watch watch what
Nicholas bee does with Rachel Maddow on
Bill Maher and do that every day because
that was probably one of the most
satisfying media moments I've ever
witnessed and and sometimes I just I
have a DVR'd sometimes I just rewind it
to that moment where Rachel Maddow gets
so mad at Nick who's using he's actually
very restrained and is using common
sense which is the enemy of emotionalism
and and she just looks like you don't
know me and that was a that was a major
victory so just just keep preaching the
common sense that's all you have to do
like you don't you don't need conspiracy
theories you don't need the wild
observations you can just literally
point out simple flaws and offer an even
better consistent solution I think it's
sort of an uphill battle because I don't
think libertarianism is the default
philosophical position for many people
so I think most people don't have a
philosophical position and that's the
problem I think most people when they
discuss politics become so emotional and
that has become so accepted that the
problem is when you try and insert some
logic so we're stuck with the chatter
screaming at each other you're stuck
with Chris Christie and you have to use
words like undisciplined when you talk
about any other questions yes Raskin
from Bloomberg News I know that I'm
speaking ex officio or unofficial so
what I mean I guess so I'm younger than
all you I mean I I know that there was
this fancy
I knew that there is a story everyone
tells me that there was everyone tells
me that there was a golden like there is
a golden age and it was like that the
Golden Age of MTV and they used to put
videos on TV which I didn't know which I
didn't know until recently and you know
like you know cook or discard thanks
because right now you sound like a
Kardashian okay sorry sorry it's bad I
guess it's better than looking like a
Kardashian so I guess my question is no
you've gotten your beard is not thick
enough my cranium is not thick enough
either
but anyway so my question is uh what do
you guys think about the the current
crop of both celebrities and the current
crop of people covering them so like how
does Amanda Bynes and and Lindsay Lohan
compare to - like Courtney Love yeah and
then the people who's your who is your
counterpart today and what do you think
about her I mean current has
counterparts on MTV because there's
still people who do MTV News there are
no more VJs I mean there's there really
are not I guess it would be people on
the radio and I'm a radio morning music
DJ so I guess I'm my counterpart and I'm
a huge fan of mine but it's you know
it's it's sad it's a train wreck but at
the same time it's also a gift and I
just keep wondering when Andy Dick and
Amanda Bynes are gonna get married
because those are some realities spawn
that I want to follow for decades that
sort of thing is eternal I mean there
are always people like that there's
always Amanda Bynes there's you know
there's always the Bieber's of the world
something wrong with it and people like
that sort of thing fine why not but it's
always been with us it's back to the 40s
especially I mean Jim's magazine or
something so I don't think is anything
new about that and we shouldn't be upset
about it the culture is not coming to an
end of course everyone here knows that
so forget it and Justin Bieber by the
way has totally abandoned his monkey in
Germany and that is not a euphemism
yes hi Kennedy how are you how are you
very well hi Jerry
what how optimistic or pessimistic are
you on the future traction of
libertarian ideas and what is the
ideological trend of the MTV generation
that's a great question and something
that that I really love and another
reason I wanted to write the book is
because the people who were my age when
I was on MTV cuz I was you know kind of
part of the demographic having started
so young they're now having kids they're
paying taxes they're involved in issues
because they can't help it and one of
the reasons the 90s was so great is
because it was prosperous and peaceful
and now our economy sucks and we're
spending a lot of money still fighting
wars still funding entitlements still
destroying small business with Obamacare
and the more people see that firsthand
the more they realized that both parties
absolutely suck Falls and there has to
be a better alternative and that
alternative is sitting right in front of
them and that is the consistent
political philosophy that is
libertarianism and most people I know
whether they know it or not are
libertarians you know thank goodness I
had Kurt Loder in my life to show me
what that meant and that's our job for
other people it's like really you want
to have a handgun in your house and you
support same-sex marriage libertarian
I feel better about the world see I was
great it is there anyone else that's it
no more questions thank you very much
everybody
have another drink thank you very very
much
what's that oh and I will be